Beautiful.
Yeah.
While it will be easy to spend
the rest of the day relaxing
on this beautiful beach, there's
work to be done underwater.
That snapper I just tasted
is exactly what I need
for my big cook, and
legendary local spear
fisherman Tony is the
man who's going to get
me within striking range.
[splash]
OK, captain.
I'm gonna follow you.
Which way?
Got you.
Over to you, sir.
[splash]
I'm a strong swimmer,
but as I'm diving down,
I'm literally being
swept sideways.
Tony explains that the fish that
normally swim above the reef
are taking shelter from
the relentless current.
He dives deep down to
check out some small caves
where the fish find protection.
I'm not joining
him, because we're
free diving with no
supplemental oxygen.
If I get trapped in one of those
caves, it would be game over.
[music playing]
That's nice.
That's good.
I'll take it.
A crab.
Nice one.
A king crab is a great catch,
but I still have my heart
set on that amazing snapper.
OK.
Good luck.
So I think we've
come up with a plan.
Tony goes down into the
cave, flushes them out,
and it's like a teamwork.
I'm sat on top of it, and
I dive and take them out.
OK.
Bingo.
I started seeing these fish
scupper underneath that cave.
I took my shot.
[speargun shooting]
And I got it.
Woo.
Yes.
Thank god for that.
Nice one.
Woo.
Finally.
That was a big one
down there as well.
Good job, bud.
I got one.
He got two.
Teamwork made the dream work,
and now snapper is officially
on my menu for the big cook.
[music playing]